pendant cinq ans avec des collègues
motivés au sein du groupe l'est
républicain
j'ai tenté de faire valoir décidé très
utile pour le pays je me suis associé à
tous les travaux du groupe pour défendre
l'assemblée nationale nous avons à
chaque proposition de voir chaque projet
de loi fait des suggestions utiles pour
améliorer les textes qui nous était
proposé nous avons été je le dis tout au
long des cinq ans force de proposition
et c'est en confiance avec tous ses
collègues que nous avons cherché à faire
valoir d'autres d'autres solutions une
alternative à ce que le maquereau nisme
tenté d'incarner se considère désormais
que ce combat doit encore être menées je
sais donc candidat dans cette optique
c'est au sein de la première
circonscription dépose une fidélité un
message à nos et celui de philippe
séguin a été pendant très longtemps le
député de cette circonscription avec un
message pour allemand singulier efforts
pour la république pour l'égalité des
chances pour la défense de la nation et
le respect de la france c'est dans ce
big three qui incarne cette journée
d'adieux
et encore et toujours faire porter ses
mots ses valeurs au coeur du valais vaud
et puis je m'engage avec l'investiture
l'époque les républicains je lisais
amplifiant ce parce que je considère
encore et toujours que les courants de
droite doit être maintenue au sein du
parlement qu'il ya la place pour faire
entendre une voix pour faire entendre
des solutions pour faire entendre les
idées neuves incarné par une forte part
une force politique libre indépendante
constructive quelle idée de faire gagner
la france donc c'est en confiance que je
m'engage dans le cadre de ces élections
législatives
[Musique]